you all know the target  shiva's dominant and only  the dominant how do we even know the  girl will be a monk  our kind do not question orders we  follow them  sergeant let's summon their icon  [Music]  our foe will not relinquish their mother  crystal easily  this will be a bitter fight  you should not be out of doors we have  discussed this  come joshua your father will be  expecting us  i am joshua's shield  [Music]  i'm sworn to protect  [Music]  what do him mean you refuse did you not  pledge your sword to our cause  what does it matter it was the dull max  who drove back the crusaders and the  battle of the twin realms  without the blessing of the mother  crystal we cannot defend our realm from  the spread of the black  [Music]  imperial vipers do they really mean to  invade us  it's the archduke's son  phoenix  but that's impossible  the legacy of the crystals  has shaped our history  enough  i'll kill you  if it's the last thing i do  [Music]  you